[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american mystery
adventure television series called the
mysterious benedict society spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the movie is set far in
the future our world is secretly being
attacked by a mysterious force that is
making people more anxious every day
because of the anxiety the illusion of
international panic known as the
emergency is created it has induced
citizens with a fear of something bad
happening which in turn messes with the
economy and other factors plaguing the
world rainey is an orphan who loves to
read and enjoys his own company he wants
to make friends but the children in the
orphanage make fun of him for being
intelligent he often feels out of place
mostly because the others aren't half as
smart as him his only mentor is his
tamil language teacher miss perumal one
day she shows him an advertisement about
a test in which the winners are awarded
a scholarship to attend a prestigious
school called the boat right academy
rainey has always wanted to go to
boatwright but he doubts his own
abilities miss paramon assures him that
he will be the most deserving one out of
all the attendees of the test the next
morning she comes to pick him up then
they drive to the examination hall and
separate after a hug many children
alongside him have come to take the test
their examiner is number two a quirky
but strict woman who briefs them on what
they can and cannot do rainy looks at
the first question which asks him if he
has a chance to save only one between an
elephant and a llama falling from a
height who would he save rainey answers
that he would save the elephant in hopes
that it could break the llama's fall and
both of them would survive
after answering several such questions
with answers related to compassion he
reaches the last one that asks him if he
is brave rainy takes time to think about
it and answers that he would like to
think so number two asks them to drop
their pencils
she grades the papers as the students
wait patiently after finishing she
informs them that the students who pass
this test will be admitted to the second
phase of the exam they should report to
a building in the next block at exactly
1pm she also emphasizes that they are
only allowed to bring a single pencil
and eraser to the test when rainey asks
her if they will be provided with
sharpeners in case the lead breaks she
answers that they will have everything
necessary for the test then she reads
the list of students who passed that
only has rainey's name on it everyone
else disappointedly leaves the premises
while rainey goes to the next
examination hall while walking inside a
girl before him named ronda accidentally
drops her pencil into a sewer drain
ronda's friend abandons her and walks
inside but rainy offers to help her they
only have a few minutes before the exam
starts so he breaks his pencil into two
and hands one half to her confident that
a sharpener will be provided inside she
expresses gratitude and offers to show
him the answers during the test but
rainey declines the offer in the
examination hall number two explains to
them that anyone who speaks during the
test will be dismissed she also adds
that the test will be long and difficult
a girl groans at the comment and is
disqualified for making noise rainy
raises his hand and gestures that he
needs to sharpen his pencil number two
understands and allows him to do so the
test finally starts and only a few
seconds in a boy runs away shouting that
he cannot do this rainy focuses on the
questions which are too difficult for
him to understand most of them are
advanced level questions about world
history and geography still rhonda who
is seated right before rainey finishes
in only half an hour before submitting
the answers she secretly drops a small
piece of paper for rainey he notices the
paper has all the answers on it although
rainy is struggling with the questions
he doesn't pick it up the atmosphere is
intense as some students almost cry
because of the difficult questions
rainey knows none of the answers but
upon reading the questions carefully he
realizes that the answer to the first
question is hidden in the last question
in the same way all of the answers are
in the questions themselves after
finding that out he easily writes them
down and does great on the test a while
later the result is announced and again
only rainy passes it is surprising to
him because rhonda has cheated she
wishes him luck and leaves him to wait
for further instruction then an a-grade
student named sticky washington enters
the room sticky has an eidetic memory
meaning he can remember everything he
sets his eyes on he was also the only
one who passed the test in his batch
which he thinks is weird because someone
else had cheated it turns out that they
had the same experience before the test
and met the same girl who dropped her
pencil in the sewage they figure out the
actual aim of the trick was to test
their loyalty and kindness therefore
they passed and the other students who
only focused on the questions did not
suddenly a girl comes running to the
room and introduces herself as kate she
is an athletic and adventurous girl who
never goes anywhere without her red
bucket of tools kate claims that she
didn't actually pass the test because
the questions were too difficult in fact
she was selected because she helped
number two chase away all the angry
parents by creating a distraction then
krista and dewey join the group they
have also passed the exam and are pretty
confident that they will make it to the
boatwright academy krista is a
know-it-all who thinks that everyone is
inferior to her after the team has
assembled they are introduced to
milligan the overseer of the next test
he instructs them to enter a room one
after another and asks krista to go
first she walks into the room and
notices the chessboard patterned floor a
note on the floor asks her to cross the
room without stepping on the black or
white squares she bluntly says no
refusing to do the task because she
thinks it is a trick question milligan
disqualifies her and asks her to go home
next dewey enters the room and uses his
athletic abilities to jump to the yellow
squares he sticks to the wall and leaps
to the other end of the room easily
after he passes kate enters with her red
bucket of tools she uses a rope from her
bucket and ties it tightly to make a
pathway kate used to work in a circus
for a long time and can easily walk on
ropes she uses her skills to reach the
other end and complete the task when it
is sticky's turn he reads the question
carefully and figures out that it
specifically asks them to not step with
their feet so he instead gets on all
four and crosses the room lastly rainy
thinks for a long time and simply walks
to the other end of the room when asked
how he passed the test he claims that
the boxes had longer lengths which means
that they weren't squares since the
question asked them to not step on the
squares he simply walked across and
passed after that milligan asks them to
come with him to the place where their
final test will be taken he takes them
to a sewer claiming that it is the
pathway to reach their destination the
kids find it odd that the entrance
examination to such a prestigious school
makes the finalists walk through sewage
rainey also notes that none of the
examiners have mentioned the boatwright
academy yet he still trusts milligan and
follows him to reach the front lawn of a
mansion milligan leaves them alone for a
few minutes to check if everything is
prepared inside when the kids are left
to themselves dewey starts to exercise
while the other three talk about their
families kate reveals that her mother
died when she was a little girl and her
father abandoned her in an orphanage she
doesn't blame him because that is how
she found her love for circuses rainey
also reveals that he never knew his
parents but he still misses them
generally dewey follows up with a
comment saying that his parents love him
and call him their miracle good for you
dewey following that they are called
inside the mansion that looks like a
maze rhonda appears in front of them and
reveals that she was sent to test them
for the next task they are kept in four
different parts of the maze and are
asked to find a way to reach the second
floor once they have climbed to the
second floor the first three to ring the
bell will pass as a hint ronda mentions
that they should be able to do this with
their eyes closed the task finally
starts and rainey immediately begins
looking for clues he sees that each
doorway has four signs that point in
different directions meanwhile sticky
takes the clue seriously and tries to
solve the maze with his eyes closed
because of his photographic memory he
navigates the way pretty quickly kate on
the other hand thinks out of the box she
opens a vent on the wall and uses it to
climb up at last there is dewey who
follows sticky around when he reaches
the stairs dewey pushes him to the wall
and rings the bell before everyone
rainey soon finds out that the signs are
in braille which tell him the direction
he also reaches the stairs and helps
sticky up kate is already there and is
waiting for them so they can all ring
the bell together as they do the three
win and dewey is disqualified in the
instructions it was said that the first
three to ring the bell will win and
because sticky kate and rainey were the
three who rang it together they won
following that they are introduced to
the mastermind of the test mr nicholas
benedict as they talk about further
orientation the fourth and youngest
member named constance joins their team
she is a small intelligent and witty
girl who doesn't care about what anyone
thinks it turns out that she passed the
test a bit differently than the others
first she crossed all the questions
claiming that they were wrong then she
disobeyed the instructions and brought
as many pencils as she wanted and in the
last test she enjoyed a sandwich instead
of solving the maze her unique
personality still got her selected then
for the moment of truth mr benedict
tells them that they haven't been
recruited for boatwright academy's
scholarship instead they have been
selected for an undercover mission to
save the world the children can hardly
comprehend what is going on mr
cumberbatch explains that they are the
only ones who can end the emergency and
save the world from chaos it turns out
that a mysterious subliminal message is
being broadcast all around the globe
through radios and televisions when
people listen to such tv and radio shows
they only hear the sound that has the
highest frequency but behind that sound
someone has added violent messages in a
low frequency that the human ear cannot
catch although people cannot hear the
message their brain reacts to the
frequency hence they subconsciously
start to believe the message which makes
them anxious these messages have created
the illusion of international panic that
we call the emergency after a year of
research mr benedict has found out that
the signals of the messages are coming
from an island that is the home to a
children's school hence only kids are
allowed to go there therefore their
group has been selected for the task he
gives them the option to say no and is
happy that he got to meet such
intelligent kids after much thinking all
of them agree to join the mission and
start their training subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching